So my entrepreneurial experience.
I found it's abundantly obvious
when you need to hire somebody.
So you kind of go on, you have this
idea, you're working on it really hard.
You get some users,
you get some traction and
the thing that gives you the most pain
is the thing that you need to hire for
and for me it was always operations.
And just like doing deals,
advertising, getting any,
I mentioned earlier that
were in Apple retail.
That was just this woman that I hired
that just miraculously made it happen.
It was huge lots of phone calls and
meetings and so the thing about it is
you need to find the people that
are going to fill in your gaps and
they become,
I like to go until it's painful.
I've done their job for a little bit so
I know what to look for but
I hate it enough that I know I need
to get somebody else to do it.
But I really recommend,
I've seen entrepreneurs do this
where they will actually just go,
well I need to be the person before
they've actually felt that pain.
Like they think this is the playbook,
they read a book somewhere or
they heard from video or
they read the story of another company.
Every company is unique and
especially in the early days and so
your strengths are unique, so what you
need to hire first off is probably not
what any other company needed
to hire right off the bat.